so it's great to see you here at the
premiere for Sundance is a life after
Beth now I know this is your first
comedy but you're playing with a lot of
veteran comic actors weren't you yeah
how was that for you well you know that
was kind of the comforting thing about
it because I was a kind of a fish out of
water but they were they were in the
shark tank you know so yeah it was just
like I it was amazing that I got to do
my first comedy with some of my favorite
comedians and they made the job a lot
easier you know cuz they really know
what they're doing and I learned a lot
what did you learn when you were working
with them um I don't know I think I
learned like I it's hard to explain you
know but I think when you see like a
true like pro amazing comedian work like
you just you learn like it's a little
more of a conscious thing you know it's
not like for instance when you're making
like a serious kind of like indie drama
a lot of times like if you if you feel
like you want to laugh you just laugh
and you kind of just let moments happen
but in comedies like if you feel like
you want to laugh it's probably because
it's just really funny and you gotta
keep keep you keep it together you know
in a very different movie coming out
later this year the amazing spider-man 2
how much burners have been making that
and what kind of stuff did you learn
that can again it's very different lots
of green screen and that kind of stuff
yeah I mean spider-man was an amazing no
pun intended experience and I think the
movie is gonna be really dynamic and you
know human but huge action sequences and
you know it was nice to have six months
to make a film these like a film and
independent film like this we make in
20-some days so to have six months like
that's a real luxury and the production
value is amazing and yeah that was a
another great experience I've been
really lucky we look forward to that
many more movies for me thanks - oh
thanks
you